we are welcoming back to Bachelorette on
ABC Monday night May 28th 8:00 p.m.
Eastern Time 7:00 central on ABC and
this man throat 1/2 here in studio built
quite a has built quite a career for
himself
the host of the bachelor Miss America
and Who Wants to Be a Millionaire all
rolled into one good to see you cross
all packed into one year I know
I mean you've host the Bachelorette and
then you're following the footsteps of
Bert parks now I I'm actually I'm
actually second to Bert parks now yeah
and I don't know if we're gonna be doing
it this year but I've done it since
pretty much off and on since 2004 Miss
America and so I think I rank second of
the longest-running host for Miss
America and of course mr. TV Regis
Philbin my footsteps getting to do Who
Wants to Be a Millionaire is great I'm
in my third year of that the daytime
syndication and check local listings and
it's it's a blast it is I mean look I
we're host students of the game and so
when you get to walk into a Yankee
Stadium type place like millionaire and
that you know arena it's it's not lost
on me who was there before me and and I
loved it I loved doing it well one of
the things that if you don't mind me
saying work so you you do so well is
you're genuine which you need to have
for for something like what you're doing
with the Bachelorette I mean in The
Bachelor because there's so much emotion
going on now I understand that we're
still just talking in the in the real
world about the toy department right but
I mean what happened with Becca was
something that I used the phrase
national kerfuffle yes you as your horse
racing days point out would be a very
good horse name right that was based on
what was going on with her last year now
who do you hear from personally when
things like well that happens done yeah
I mean in in ari's particular instance
it was a few weeks after you know I
actually ran into him I run into him
from time to time
you know we're doing press or doing
whatever and I say how you doing and
instead of the glowing oh my gosh Beck
and I are great we just can't get enough
of each other we're you know we're on
our happy couple dates there was the you
know every now and then he'd throw in
you know Becca's great but I can't stop
thinking about Lauren I said well you
know it was a bad breakup I know it was
tough on you and you know that'll
subside and you know keep moving on and
you'll be good because I really
he and Beckett were doing good and then
it just it got to be more and more and
then a producer called and said this is
happening but so to put this in
real-world perspective yes this is my
issue I had one week set aside in my
life that I blacked out last year this
year and that was to play in the 18 t
Pebble Beach pro-am do not call me do
not mess with me I don't ask for much
okay I'm off the radar I get a call the
day before I'm leaving
we need you next week no I'm teeing it
up with Jason Day at the AT&T I don't
care who's online that's not happening
they like and then they told me what
happened they were like okay so this is
what's going down Ari's having is his
date with Becca this weekend and he's
breaking off with her and before all
that happens we need him to talk to you
and and discuss this and I said well
it's happening then tomorrow at my house
because then I'm leaving and everyone
can just deal with what deal with it and
that's what happened that's what
happened we shot at my house in my
living room with Ari and then I set him
on his way and then while I was teeing
it up and pebble he was breaking up with
Becca I thought you were gonna say that
it was on the 18th tee you're gonna have
that conversation for 10 minutes and
then gonna be like now watch got the
shot exactly and hit that hit the ball
but it's just because again Chris
Harrison here from the Bachelorette so
many athletes are locked in on this it's
bizarre locked in on The Bachelor and
the Bachelorette who dropped some names
here first first everybody was kind of
reluctant and I call it the bachelor
closet where everyone's like you know
when I was with him at a game or I'd see
him somewhere they'd be like oh I like
your show now no no it's okay and I
think it's the likes of of you know
Jimmy Kimmel Stern a lot of these guys
are really outspoken about being huge
fans yeah Ashton Kutcher and Mila Kunis
are always talking about it I'm not
sports people and yeah but then you get
like you know some bizarre ones Dan
Jannsen okay out of the blue we're at a
charity event dan Jansen comes up
at will Clark Dwight Clark who ruined my
childhood right a Dallas guy I mean I'll
never forget I was sitting at a golf
tournament
and this guy next to me is we're at the
bar he's like you Chris Harrison said
yeah yeah yeah how you doing hey Dwight
Clark I was like you son of a [ __ ] he's
like Dallas fan I said yeah but and I'm
friends with some of the cowboy guys I
know Tony Romo and his wife watched a
lot and and Whitin and and a lot of
those guys you know I hear you see them
and they start talking about the show
and they go deep they're in it I mean
they know more details than I do Jerry
Jones
I don't know Jerry why me I know Jerry
and gene but I know Charlotte his
daughter watches and and yeah there's
there it's bizarre Clint Eastwood now
hold on a second one of the weirdest
weirdest maybe most disappointing times
in my life was I met had the honor of
meeting Clint Eastwood and he just
looked at me and I thought he was gonna
punch me which I thought would have been
great that might be just as default
looking at everybody yeah just that he
was standing there and it was like Clint
Eastwood white t-shirt holding a
Budweiser it was a it's like a Clint
Eastwood ad of what you expect and he's
looked at me and said I watch your show
from time to time and I didn't know how
to take it I wanted him to just grab me
and say you are the worst part of
America just you know just something but
that is one of those sort of like
Seinfeld penske file you are aware
moments where it could go and even like
you know I watch your show from time to
time
[Laughter]
[Music]
that's all needed to say nothing more
nothing less
and then I was left to just decipher
what that means yeah it is bizarre I'm
caught off guard you look if I walk into
you know Chili's and there's you know 20
women sitting there I'm like yeah they
probably watch the shelter when you see
ten offensive linemen from the NFL you
are thrown taking them taking it back a
little bit when they're like dude yeah
how's Becca doing really that's it's
bizarre but the show does it crosses all
borders
barriers and because everyone can relate
to it everybody gets it well I know
Chris Anderson here on the Rich Eisen
show when Becca was given the Heisman if
you will in the manner in which she was
by re line Dyke junior that if I'm not
mistaken like local politicians were
threatening to ban re from entering the
States
she's a Minnesota girl right so
Minnesota billboards put up in Minnesota
someone bought billboards and it wasn't
us they thought it was us it was not us
you know keep out of here and you're not
welcome here and then yes some is some
politician in it might have been the
governor I don't even know but it like
went off on re and like said he was no
longer welcome in the state of Minnesota
and it's if people get feeted and fired
up but now she's the Bachelorette yeah
so now she has the opportunity to well
is it fair to say turn a table because
she doesn't seem to have that sort of
gene I think what she has the ability to
do now is have perspective and and she
will get full perspective of she you
know and I will tell you know cuz we're
done filming and so I won't give
anything away but I we're in the can
we're in the can we're done okay this is
done we just wrapped about a week ago
and so I will say this while she still
doesn't appreciate how re handled this
and and I I'll admit re was a
knucklehead if and didn't handle it
perfectly but I think she appreciates
what he went through
she definitely sympathizes with how that
can happen and look we all have the
propensity to love more than one person
at a time we often don't have that
opportunity where you're dating 25 women
at once or 25 men but the bachelor
obviously in Bachelorette and forces
that situation and so you do you have
that ability and often times if you do
your job as the bachelor and
bachelorette you're left with four or
five great people that you're splitting
hairs at the end of what separates them
and so I think she understands now oh I
see what happened
and she was very cognizant of that and
very careful not to go down that road of
saying to more than one person I love
you okay so this is gonna run all the
way through to
through the summer all the summer yeah
we start this Monday by Memorial Day
yeah so that you don't have any golf
outing plan for September to you that
could be in jeopardy trying to see if
you're part of any pro-am and September
Labor Day sort of pro-am situation
there's any day off what is your game
like right right now it's not bad I'm
pretty good this is my this is my summer
you know December January February all
this you know heading into the season is
my is my game and then sadly when when
all the member guests all the big
tournaments are in the summer that's
when I quit playing golf because I'm
about to leave and go shoot paradise
that's done in Mexico and then I start
production on millionaire which is in
Vegas and then all of a sudden it's
September again and I'm back into
bachelor and all of a sudden it's
Thanksgiving well congressional race
myself to my kids again yeah how many do
you have to 16 and 14 yeah you're down
the road it's it's bizarre
it's really bizarre I was just talking
my my son who's 16 years old and driving
and my daughter's on this big trip right
now with her school so it's me and my
boy and he drives and I'm not needed at
all mm-hmm okay so I have to ask you the
question if you don't mind me asking
them sure you've gotten it I get all the
time when I let my kids play football
you know and I said I have to think
about it right would you let your kids
be the bachelor or the Bachelorette be
easier to let them play football and get
there here's my answer to pretty much
anything as far as I go I hope I have
raised them well enough that's correctly
it instilled upon them my values and and
that whatever they do they will make the
right choice you'll make the right
choice in life
just remember dad's always watch it
that's right they can phone a friend
exactly
dad's always watch that's always the
phone a friend good to see you man
we'll see you in the big slick corrected
yes yeah my buddy rob riggle is one of
the guys Eric Stonestreet Jason Sudeikis
I'll put this on you've been there and
Riggle says it's a great event we're
going to Kansas City it is rich eyes and
I will be there if that's not enough to
draw people out it's correct but look we
get to play bass
while I guess at the keg is it still
called Kaufman it is Kaufman stage okay
because usually when they rebuild
stadiums it's like yeah whatever yeah
it's like dot-com drop in whatever it is
I'm so yeah we're playing softball there
we're eating barbecue and drinking beer
and there'll be a lot of Swing oil yeah
one of my favorite do we have time for
one of my favorite sports moments ever
because I'm a big sports guy and the
first time I ever got to throw out the
first pitch was oddly enough I was doing
this job in Kansas City and they said
would you throw out the first pitch said
who's there
Royals and Rangers awesome my Rangers
yeah this is great from the Metroplex
and I go out to the Kauffman Stadium I'm
throwing out the first pitch rain delay
delayed an hour
Royals weren't great this is like a
while ago when they really sucked so
there's you know 14 fans there cut it in
half cuz the rain delay I walked out
nobody's there and all you can hear you
know throwing out the first pitch died
from The Bachelor Chris Harrison
Harrison Harrison all you hear you sure
that's it because you could hear one
person yell did he did he get in your
kitchen I mean the weird thing is my dad
that was weird
yeah Henry like twist to the end sort of
like laughs he's taken care of a lot but
that was my great so I was so excited I
was like this is my moment I am on top
of the world and then just boom do you
throw a strike I brought it damn
straight you did probably eat 45 miles
if not 46 straight
damn straight was like 10 or 15 years
ago okay
okay so then you you left a rose for
Kevin Brown on the mound exact exact Wow
try to think the Bachelorette airing
Monday May 28 that 8:00 p.m. Eastern on
ABC will see you in Kansas City in a
couple I'll be there please come back
anytime thanks Richard you got that's
Chris Harrison at Chris B Harrison on
Twitter the Rich Eisen show weekdays at
noon eastern on audience